la movilización de hoy es considerada
como la más importante para la luna en
este inicio de campaña porque se realiza
en un lugar muy simbólico para la
izquierda brasileña el vale do
anhangabaú en el centro de la ciudad de
san pablo donde hubo en 1984 una
manifestación histórica para pedir
elección directa al final del régimen
militar la campaña de lula quiere
mostrar así que su candidatura también
es para defender la democracia contra
los ataques de gea bolsonaro al sistema
electoral y a la corte suprema el jefe
de estado participó por la mañana en una
ceremonia militar aquí en el estado de
río de janeiro pero no hizo ningún
discurso la última encuesta de opinión
que fue publicada este viernes por el
instituto datafolha que es el más
confiable muestra que hay unos 15 puntos
porcentuales entre los dos candidatos 47
por ciento para lula y 32 para
evolucionar en los efectos del paquete
de gastos sociales no son perceptibles
hasta en las encuestas y el presidente
muestra las señales de nerviosismo
se peleó ayer con influenciador
agarrando
al joven por el brazo y la camiseta
cuando estaba filmando un vídeo
faltan 40 días para la primera vuelta y
bolsonaro necesita un empuje
para evitar en primer lugar una victoria
de lula en primera vuelta que las
encuestas indican como